давайте меня зовут стив и я но я отвечу
на одного из моих целей
который меня спросил я видел по русски
конечно levaquin брат что есть люди
которые хотят
мне слушать на их родном языке я не знаю
просто история будет сказать за день 23
года я больше всего
изучай занимала
чешском румынском корейском и сейчас
украинском поэтому мой русский
я думаю там на место много проблемах но
оле оле украинский но все равно не будь
я люблю изучать языки это мне очень
нравится и я получаю большое
удовольствие из этого
и это тоже основном тема моих моих видео
с youtube если вы посмотрите видите
подобной потом дальше большинство мои
видео я беру терры по-английски потому
потому что это для меня
лифте и я думаю что
а число люди которые не слушают они
понимают английский не обязательно
понимают русский французский я
по-японски или другие языки тема как
изучать языки огня самое важное это
и это иметь удовольствие наслаждаться не
боится
потому что когда мы думают немецкий на
мягком языке в русском и людски там есть
много
сложные грамматические легла и я знаю
когда я говорю по русски я я делаю много
ошибок и это не важно потому что потому
что у меня есть цели могу я хочу
понимать я молодая и поэтому я я
например я очень люблю смотреть
советский фильм
советских имя это это очень-очень
здорово я понимаю и когда я смотрю фильм
по русски я понимаю я очень рад что до
того
стоя изучали это это язык я очень редко
говорю по-русски
очень редко общаюсь с людьми по русски
но я могу читать и слушать я понимаю
если у меня будет возможность посетить
россию на буду говорить и мои
уровень русский будут t будет
увеличивать это тоже самое знаем
изучение украинского украинский язык и
там я это это начинало когда все это и я
событие в украине начинал несколько
месяцев тому назад я искал источник
интернете и там беру discussed
украинские то ли введения телебачення
проблем который называется shines
through я понял что говорили
все эти политики по по-русски
но я не понял что говорили украинские
политики которые говорили по украински
но сейчас после 2 месяцев 2 проведя
месяцев изучения украинский украинскую
мову я понимаю ну это мой чек и когда я
я 2 3 4 1 я говорю по-украински с наши
клинки есть моя учительница то по-русски
это же покрытия алена я говорил
34 газ с очень много трудностей а она
есть я всегда хочу сказать аллы
украинский и я не думаю что тот факт что
я изучал части и украинский в кровь
крутки срочной перспективе это мешает
мои русские то это это плохой плохое
влияние на мой русский но бандурко срок
срочной перспективе это помогает потому
что эти языки них есть очень похоже
грамматики хотя словами запас печати
и это это
этой части славянский мир
славянский культуры хотя у каждого
культура каждого я языке есть свои
особенности но я большинство мои видео я
беру по-английски вы можете послушать
так я например я говорю что я думаю что
мы должны имеет удовольствием
наслаждаться не боится грамот егор не
собирается сосредоточиться на грамматика
это не значит что вы не должен изучать и
читать иногда книги у кровати но это не
должен быть центр наше понимание что
сказать я говорю по-английски и довольно
четко не очень быстро и поэтому вы
можете не слушать английский и я я
надеюсь что это помогает
на ваше изучение английского языка
если воздействие вопросов несколько бы
вы можете меня
спросить я следовал всем на
попробую ответить этого
обед на обед на одно а много-много из
моих слушателей
который сказал что я очень долго не
делал видео по русски
извините извините за все всех мальчик
ошибки до свидания